criticado por mantener una línea abierta
con el presidente de rusia enmanuel
makoun dijo que las conversaciones eran
la única manera de poner fin a la guerra
en ucrania en un momento dado cuando
hayamos apoyado al máximo la resistencia
cuando ucrania haya ganado y los
combates puedan cesar deberemos negociar
los en su intervención junto a su
homólogo rumano el presidente francés
afirmó que europa apoyará a ucrania
hasta su victoria sobre rusia el viaje
de mayo es una muestra simbólica del
apoyo al flanco oriental de europa fue
una oportunidad para que visitará a los
aproximadamente 500 soldados franceses
estacionados en una base militar de la
otan donde francia también ha desplegado
un sistema de misiles tierra-aire
después de rumanía mccone se dirigió a
moldavia que se enfrenta a una fuerte
afluencia de refugiados desde que
comenzó la guerra en febrero francia ya
presta ayuda financiera al país unos
400.000 refugiados susana nos han
entrado a moldavia y aunque muchos se
han ido a países vecinos unos 80.000 han
decidido quedarse
la gran incógnita que rodea su viaje es
seguir a ucrania aunque la pregunta yo
esta enigmática respuesta mostra las
puertas de nuestra unión europea está en
juego una situación geopolítica sin
precedentes así que si el contexto
político y las decisiones que la unión
europea y varias naciones tendrán que
tomar justifican nuevos debates en
profundidad y nuevos avances y universos
macua es uno de los pocos líderes de la
unión europea que aún no ha pisado
ucrania desde el estallido de la guerra